sandwich the sandwich combat this is war
right now hey what's going on everybody
first we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at
you from lower Manhattan where I'm
joined by a familiar face Action Bronson
back in the building
a lawyer so I'm feeling so good you've
been a busy guy blue chip 7000 is out
now vice land [ __ ] that's delicious you
already know and speaking of you as a
cook book of the same name an annotated
guide to eating well out September 12th
and that's why we're back at Mile End
it's another good old-fashioned kitchen
throwdown this time its sandwich stack
vers sandwich stack sean evans vs.
action bronson may the best man win
bam bam ready to get it going let's go
let's go i have to ask as i'm sure you
have a strong opinion what makes the
perfect sandwich the bread it's the meat
it's the thing that goes on is a little
slather that makes everything moist it's
the hint of this it's a little touch of
that it's all over the place there's
really no one way to make us sandwiches
whatever makes you feel good all right
well what are you gonna be making today
I'm gonna be making a recipe out of my
book naturally and I'm gonna make the
chicharrón sandwich which is straight-up
pork belly that smoked I'm gonna make a
marmalade of jalapenos blackberries and
raspberries some robiola bosina cheese
for the creaminess you can't go wrong
there do you have a shot you have a
puncher's chance good you just never
know what's gonna happen that's the
beauty of fights and that's the beauty
of sandwich AHA it's the beauty of
hand-to-hand combat you never know
what's gonna happen
sandwich the sandwich combat this is war
right now
[Music]
then I'm gonna slice up the jalapenos
now to make this raspberry blackberry
just summer berry jalapeno chutney
marmalade cyberfield I like that a
little heat with the sweetener season
sweet that's what it's all about I
always keep the seeds in I don't know
why anyone won't want to take the seeds
out it's like that's what the flavor is
that's where you get all the heat I want
to taste that you ever had robiola
bolsena
I'm so excited I have not just look how
creamy that is see that damn take a
little slab of this tell me what you
think luxurious it's ridiculous you know
in the same way that you layer flavors
you layer textures - am i right exactly
raspberries they're nice berries now
blackberries down that's about a third
of a cup of sugar some salt you don't
want it to be too sugary a little more
so now just let it show those fruits are
gonna let those juices out there's gonna
get soft and create this zero it's just
gonna be a perfect little tart hint to
this salty scrumptious bacon with this
[ __ ] cheese now onto this slab bacon
so now we're just gonna make little
dientes in this it's kind of like when
you go to a Colombian bakery in the
morning you could get a big piece of
cheese on her own you just eat that for
breakfast you know it doesn't really
need any oil just pop it on the grill
it's just it's bacon there's gonna be so
much fat that comes off that let's just
let that rock
[Music]
later Sean so quickly didn't even too
much yeah you can just kind of just spin
the down it'll start to well right now
that salt makes everything extract and
heat now we just need it all to melt
together to become this unbelievable
thing to [ __ ] beat you throw a little
bit more luxurious in this a little mail
little mayo on it I'm even gonna go with
some fresh sliced jalapeno chill but the
ends but special about the ends I don't
know it's just leftover so I said
[ __ ] my own of me alright well it
looks like a formidable opponent for
sure I hope coming out so I know you're
serious about it I'm gonna go with the
challah bread
I'm gonna go with some melted Swiss I'm
gonna go with Turkey I'm gonna go with
some fried salami I'm just gonna throw
some salami on the griddle
um yet salami but you need something to
give it a little oomph what about some
hot sauce and maybe some maple syrup how
do you think that all that's interesting
hot sauce and maple syrup works well and
then wildcard I'm gonna reach up the
sleeve and pull out an ace I'm gonna
drop some fries and then just put that
on top are you Primanti brother in me am
I am i crossing I'm your man you did
that's why you go sitting down that's a
shame I want to make sure yeah I want to
see how high I wanna put fries in mine
to think that goes higher
right Hostel annual tossing got some of
the residual bacon grease on it if you
got that that's my other strategy that's
my other move I'm grabbing the things
that you leave behind I'm putting them
all in my salami on the griddle salami
on the griddle
she'd drop the fry now I'll get the
salami off for you
and you know I'm nervous a little
nervous
heart beating a little bit I just placed
your bread
they're just laced your bread with some
of that salami fat so you're gonna put
me across the finish line no no it's a
collaboration it's a collab but you're
gonna win how's it good those are good
those are good pop them out instantly
interesting so little little salt
actions little bull talk
[Music]
all right here we go melt it up those
that's a beautiful cross that gorgeous
these are fresh it's time to take it to
the judge and we have a pretty special
judge I think so
yeah little cross section action I've
got fours ready to go right you [ __ ]
leave one piece for us to keep this is
something happen to that to the judges
to the judge's table man here we are at
the judge's table and anything can
happen when you're having a sandwich
throwdown so we have a very special
surprise guest judge Mario Batali's here
I was just walking down the street he
was evil accosted me that's what happens
that's what happens when I have in the
kitchen throwdown so action do you want
to start yeah I'll start okay so this is
a chicharrón in a Colombian style you
know when you go in the morning to the
bakery the Colombian bakeries they have
this big piece of cheese shot on pork
belly yes that's that on bread okay a
slice of robiola boss Gina for the
creaminess the Roby la piscina has not
served in that bakery no definitely my
twisted mind and pawns in himself
exactly all right and then I made a
little bit of a marmalade type of hot
sauce with some jalapenos blackberries
and raspberries since we are in season
it's so regional thank you very sinal
these are the hours of waters of Oz
wrappers they're white fantastic well
what do you think I learned it I got I
learned to eat regionally and seasonally
from you sir fantastic fantastic and
then I used some sliced raw jalapeno to
add a little imp at the end I made
toasted one side that's the underbelly
of the bread okay
for what reason I'm not sure but I
thought it was a thing I think
[Music]
that's what we call commitment now
you've never that was a big league by
Triton corks night the row bill is part
of my heartstrings I know how to tell
you tell the blackberries remind me of
my childhood
looking good you're looking really
really good do you get the jalapeno at
all the fresh I got you know what I
needed another one okay maybe they
weren't a sponge enough I could take a
little more kick but you know why write
your rhymes it doesn't always have to
smack you in the face
yeah you know what I might say about
that sandwich [ __ ] that's delicious
all right all right
Mario give the challah bread no we're in
a place called Mile End do they approve
that you call it color challah bread all
right and then we have some melted Swiss
we threw some salami on the griddle
piled up some turkey little mayo and
then here's where we go off the beaten
path love it
we went with some fancy brothers style
fries on top and then we went with a
little bit of Tapatio and then some
maple syrup just just to go there just
go there I can't help but notice that
one corner of my sandwich is missing
it's a good [ __ ] sandwich I already
know the toasting is a little better
here you should put the toast on the
actual proper Center turkey is
beautifully seasoned wherever you got
the turkeys fantastic the fries have
created something truly fashioned that I
like oh it's gonna stand a good way
no in a fantastic way these are two
fantastic sandwiches
you have to crown a champion and let me
just get the details here mm-hmm
this is your show and he's a guest [ __ ]
me well for that reason alone oh not the
action yeah
not action they're in cahoots they're in
cahoots yeah say I thought you were
gonna win I have to say so I would be
very happy to eat either of these
sandwiches breakfast lunch dinner late
night and either of you could be naked
in the sea
wouldn't bother because all I would
think it would motivate off
high praise and you know what if you
want to learn how to make a sandwich
like this you're so you know what to do
[ __ ] that's delicious the cookbook
September 12 Mario thank you for joining
me I have an action
always a pleasure my man thank you very
much I'll take the 50 later best Sean
Evans from first we feast Mario Batali
Action Bronson rap Mile End having a
good old-fashioned kitchen throw down
its sandwich off 2017 look for it on
first we feast